totally not Mark's complete list of
Gohan's best hairstyles super Gohan
Gohan's worst hairstyle by a mile to top
off this list is whatever Abomination he
had during the bulk of Dragon Ball super
ultimate Gohan it's just the last one
with a bang his first hairstyle I think
this is fine High School Gohan at the
end of the day it's still not as good as
the other options in my opinion
superhero perfect for this point in
Gohan's life and I'm here for it
Resurrection F extra points for making
him look like a salary man future Gohan
you might have noticed that adult Gohan
isn't my favorite style of Gohan Kid
Gohan Saiyan Invasion go on in this
material is very much a child among
monsters Goku's meeting with trunks I
think one of the coolest parts of
Gohan's hairstyle during this time is
that unlike Goku and Vegeta his hair
actually grows teen Gohan bonus points
for a changing also when he goes Super
Saiyan 2 it looks awesome bowl cut Gohan
bowl cut Gohan is Peak I had the same
haircut as a kid too which solidified
this cut for me on this list